fans have been waiting forever for their
first full glimpse at the matrix
resurrections and the first official
trailer showed a new status quo for neo
and a ton of hints as to what's really
going on here's some of the small
details you missed in the trailer the
trailer kicks off with neo talking to a
mysterious therapist played by neil
patrick harris although only we get a
brief blink and you'll miss it look at
neo's prophetic visions it's definitely
interesting that harris's character is
wearing such big blue glasses they seem
to be a nod to the blue pills which keep
neo subdued in the matrix and it's
possible the machines are using the
therapist as a new way of convincing the
hero that everything is fine taking a
multi-pronged approach to stop the one
however neil patrick harris previously
told the jess kegel show that he has a
small part in this sequel so don't
expect him to show up all the way
through the therapist's blue glasses
aren't the only intriguing eyewear in
the film as yaya abdul mateen ii's
circular glasses are also extremely
similar to the ones morpheus wears in
the original trilogy most of the scenes
we see abdul mateen ii show up in are
very reminiscent of the things morpheus
gets up to in the classic films the
trailer clearly riffs on the iconic dojo
fight when a red-robed abdul mateen
fights neo in an idyllic location a
previous report suggested lawrence
fishburne isn't coming back to play
morpheus because warner brothers wanted
to use a younger version of the
character if that's true that's probably
the reason behind abdul mateen's casting
just about 45 seconds into the trailer
you can see a business sign to the right
as neo walks down a city street the sign
reads corki's massage which to most
people probably seems meaningless for
this detail lana wachowski isn't
actually calling back to anything from
previous matrix films instead this is a
reference to a past film that the
wachowskis worked on all the way back in
1996 even before the matrix written and
directed by the wachowski siblings
1996's bound was actually their
feature-length directorial debut so the
movie holds a lot of significance for
them inbound the protagonist is an
ex-criminal named corki who is played by
gina gershon the movie is a neo-noir
crime drama in which corki helps a woman
named violet played by jennifer tilly
get away from her violent
mafia-associated boyfriend caesar all
the while falling in love with the woman
herself the corki's massage sign is only
a small detail in the new trailer but
it's a great little callback for both
the director and longtime fans of her
and her sister's work
while the trailer is full of callbacks
to former matrix films one of the
biggest and most famous references to
the start of the trilogy is the
appearance of a rabbit tattoo in the
original matrix neo was told to follow
the white rabbit when his computer
screen took on a mind of its own and
started sending him messages when du
jour and choi go to neo's apartment to
pick up some illegal software he built
for them the couple asks him to come out
with them to a club after turning down
the offer neo reconsiders when he sees a
white rabbit tattoo on djour's left
shoulder blade this was all trinity's
doing who used the lure of the tattoo to
get neo to the club so they could have
their first meeting it looks like the
rabbit tattoo will have the same kind of
purpose in resurrections jessica
henwick's character has a tattoo of the
animal on her right upper arm which
looks to trigger a memory in neo's mind
she sports blue hair which suggests she
might be bad news but he still follows
her through a mysterious door anyway
after following the white rabbit in the
first film neo might be conditioned to
do so subconsciously in this one but
this time it might not be the best
decision while this is one you really
can't miss about a minute into the new
trailer there is a woman at a cafe who
neo approaches she closes a book called
through the looking glass the sequel to
the original alice's adventures in
wonderland if you have a keen eye you
might recognize this woman as actress
priyanka chopra who is a new addition to
the franchise in the matrix
resurrections we don't see much of the
actress's character in the trailer but
she already has people theorizing about
her role with big glasses and a knowing
look many think that she could be the
new version of the oracle the important
figure was first played by gloria foster
but after she passed in 2001 mary alice
took over the role for the film the
matrix revolutions given that it's been
around 18 years since that film's
release it wouldn't be surprising to see
the character recast and altered for the
new movie another theory that some fans
have is that chopra jonas may be playing
the grown-up version of the character
sati who is seen with the oracle in the
matrix revolutions in the 2003 film sati
is a young girl being protected because
the oracle thinks she may have an
important role to play in the future
this new trailer doesn't exactly try to
hide that the film is returning to
familiar territory a mysterious figure
at the very end of the trailer sums it
up himself
after all these years to be going back
to where it all started
back to the matrix
the office itself is the most blatant
reuse of scenery but there are several
other examples for instance neo and
abdul mateen's character duke it out in
a digital dojo that seems all too
similar from the original dojo featured
in the first matrix it's also pretty
obvious that in the scene where neo
deflects a rocket he and trinity are at
the top of a skyscraper featured in the
first film as well the skyscraper itself
is important because much of its
interior scenery is reused in this
trailer this includes the rainy sequence
which is actually the building's
sprinkler system and the lobby where neo
freezes bullets in place furthermore neo
is seen dueling an agent in a subway
tunnel just like he did with agent smith
in the first film the apartment building
where neo accompanies morpheus crew on
his first mission also seems to be
featured heavily all of this recurring
imagery almost brings on a sense of deja
vu which within the films has
historically been pretty important
what is it a deja vu is usually a glitch
in the matrix it happens when they
change something there's even a black
cat in one of the first shots of the
trailer perhaps lana wachowski is trying
to tell us something about our own world
by giving viewers a weird feeling about
these very familiar locations
you think that's air you're breathing
now
just after the two-minute mark in the
trailer fans get a quick glimpse of neo
running away from armed assailants in a
flame-filled hallway and right behind
him eagle-eyed viewers can spot that the
wall seems to read deus ex machina fans
of the original trilogy probably
remember the term deus ex machina from
the third film revolutions where the
central sentient control system based in
machine city bears that very name upon
arriving in the city neo begs the deus
ex machina to declare an end to the
seemingly endless war between humans and
machines ultimately the deus ex machina
accepts neo's offer and essentially uses
neo's body to reset the matrix deleting
all copies of the malevolent agent smith
in the process beyond that the term deus
ex machina which translates to god from
the machine has a basis in greek
tragedies in those stage plays an actor
portraying a savior figure who could fix
any problems within the story would be
brought on stage by some sort of machine
creating the term since neo with his
specific set of powers within and
outside of the matrix can salvage nearly
any situation throughout the original
three films he's also a deus ex machina
clearly lana wachowski and her team love
seriously layered references
sometimes a seemingly innocuous object
can mean a lot more than you'd realize
on the surface level look we all love a
good bath accessories so sometimes a
rubber ducky is just a rubber ducky but
sometimes it's more than that and we
have a sneaking suspicion that's the
case when we see neo relaxing in the tub
for a good soak with a rubber duck on
his head it all looks normal unless you
factor in the programming tactic of
rubber duck debugging wait what
according to thoughtful code it's a
method coders use to figure out exactly
what's wrong with something that just
refuses to compile they explain their
code line by line to the inanimate
object assuming it has no knowledge of
coding whatsoever in doing so they're
forced to analyze what's actually on the
screen instead of allowing their brains
to insert what they think should be
there and come upon the issue neo rubber
ducking in an actual bathtub seems akin
to some kind of existential reflection
he's pondering aspects of his life to
try to figure out what's wrong or
missing which he seems to stumble upon
when meeting trinity in a cafe later in
the very next scene of the trailer check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you